c'est l'une des catastrophes naturelles
les plus longues et les plus coûteuses
en 2015
direction la côte sud-ouest des
etats-unis en californie où un épisode
de sécheresse dure depuis plusieurs
années et cet été il semble en passe de
dégénérer
la végétation est extrêmement sèche les
réserves d'eau sont au plus bas
le soleil brille implacablement
des ingrédients hautement inflammable
pour embraser les grandes forêts de
conifères et de feuillus
chaque année les états du sud ouest des
états unis sont victimes de ces
incendies
mais en 2015 ils prennent des
proportions inégalées
[Musique]
les feux se déclenche simultanément aux
quatre coins de la californie mais aussi
dans l'état de washington dans l'orégon
dans l'utah et dans le montana
jusqu'à trente foyers se consume au même
moment en plein coeur de l'été
mobilisant onze mille pompiers à travers
le pays
la sécheresse a été provoquée depuis
l'hiver dernier par un système météo
figé qui empêchait les tempêtes
d'arriver en californie les pluies ont
lieu presque entièrement en hiver en
californie et ces dernières années les
modèles météo empêchait les tempêtes
d'arrivée
c'est un phénomène météorologique peu
connu qui est responsable notamment de
la sécheresse sur les côtes
californiennes l'oscillation décennale
du pacifique
il s'agit d'un refroidissement anormal
des eaux de surface du pacifique qui
repoussent les eaux chaudes vers le nord
et le sud là on est sur des phénomènes
qui oscille à l'échelle de la dizaine
d'années et qui apporte une anomalie de
température positive le long des côtes
de l'amérique du nord
sur ce schéma on voit les anomalies de
températures dans le nord du pacifique
on a toute une zone d'anomalies dont des
anomalies très très forte le long des
côtes de la californie et la ligue du
nord et ça c'est un phénomène qui
oscille sur des échelles beaucoup plus
longue donc à l'échelle de plusieurs
dizaines d'années et qui a commencé
début 2014
l'oscillation décennale du pacifique va
donc se poursuivre sur plusieurs années
mais ses répercussions sont en train de
s'effacer au profit de celle d'el niño
qui prend de plus en plus d'ampleur cet
hiver on prévoit au contraire beaucoup
de précipitations en californie et cela
pourrait mettre un terme à cette
sécheresse
on ignore si un seul hiver humide
suffire à restaurer les niveaux d'eau
mais toutes les prévisions s'accordent
sur un hiver très pluvieux en californie
le bilan de ces feux est catastrophique
c'est la plus terrible saison sèche
depuis dix ans aux états unis
trente et un mille six cents kilomètres
carrés ont brûlé dans différents états
au sud et à l'ouest du pays l'équivalent
de la surface de la région provence
alpes côte d'azur partis en fumée en
quelques mois